here he is the man of the hour certainly
on the campus at the university of
alabama
and then we cannot wait to see what
happens next
for devante smith who spent senior bowl
week
in alabama which a lot of people uh
don't usually do when they have won the
heisman trophy
and pretty much every other award that
he won this past year
on behalf of autotrader here is davonte
smith how are you sir
i'm good how about you i'm fine so how
do you rate your year collegiately
i feel like it was a good year i left
some things out there but
overall it was a good year what'd you
leave out there you won every award
what did you leave out i left i lost
some money on the table
what do you mean what are you talking
about i love some touchdowns out there
that's money on the table is that what
you're saying yeah
most definitely okay because also i
don't know are you where you
you you set eight of nine receiving
records you just
there was only one thing left on the
table and that do you know which
alabama receiving record you did not set
do you know which one that is nah what
that was it was the one it was uh
receptions in a season amari cooper got
you by seven
that's what he got a lesson on tape i
guess that's
that's all i could find that's all
literally i could find like what
touchdowns did you leave on the table
uh i know i know one for sure i left one
against mississippi state out there
well speaking on behalf is it michigan
wolverine how the hell did you leave
that out there come on
just just happened man okay what do you
mean plea i i i love this type of stuff
because it just also goes to speak to
your your level of commitment and your
uh
soon to be as you can as you will prove
professionalism
walk me through that touchdown you left
on the table davonte
i just just got too relaxed with my
hands and just dropped it
that's it yeah okay so
um let's talk about you at the next
level what are people going to get
if they draft you in the nfl um
they want coming to build and be the
hardest worker on the team and just
make the guy across from me better and
just overall just be a great teammate
and try to be a great leader
and so um what are you hearing about um
you from nfl evaluators what are you
hearing right now
um just everything that how i care
myself and things like that just keep
being who i am and just keep being me
okay and being you
is gonna be what what are you gonna
weigh when you uh set foot in
a national football league building what
are you gonna weigh for that
uh i don't know come on what like what's
your plan
i mean because you're gonna hear that
right i mean people are gonna be like
well
you know what are you what are you buck
74 is that what you are right now if you
stepped on a scale
right now um it might be only been a
minute since i weighed myself
okay very good well this is coming i
mean my gosh your hand size
everything the whole schmear you're
aware of what's coming right for you
yes sir okay just let me know if i don't
know if you know i'm uh i'm a runner
myself devante
are you aware of this no
all right then welcome to the nfl
is basically you know i've been the host
of nfl network for
18 years now and i run in my suit
at the nfl scouting combine every year
it's the logo of my show
on this mug that i have right here in
front of me um and i've broken six
seconds
only three times in 15 16 years
so
[Laughter]
don't laugh with him well he's laughing
so i thought it was okay
it's okay for you to laugh it's okay
it's all right i've i've had i've had uh
you know what what how fast can you run
you're 40. what are you going to run
your 40 in
uh i give a halfway three low four four
low
four four okay have you heard from
desmond howard the last heisman trophy
winner to
uh be a wide receiver have you heard
from him yep yes sir i talked to him
what was that conversation about um him
just being excited for me and just
congratulating me on everything and then
just us just talking football
and so what do you talk about when you
talk football like literally like what
goes
i i'd love to get in your football mind
devonte smith
we just he just pointed out some plays
and we just walked through the plays of
what i was thinking and
how i got open and things like that okay
and how you get how you get open
in terms of what just get off the line
knowing what the defender is going to do
like walking through that what i've seen
from the defender and just how pro stone
beating him and getting open who is your
ma who's your
idol growing up who did you say i want
to be like this guy in the nfl
who would that be for you um devonta
adams and kenan allen
why is that just their releases
everything that they do in their routes
the small details and everything that
they do
have you spoken to them have you ever
been connected with them no sir all
right let's go
we're going to get to work on that i
think i think you're going to find a lot
of world and a lot of doors opened up
for you how has your life changed in the
last calendar year
uh it's really been the same nothing
nothing really too crazy
just going about everything the same way
okay so who'd
ground you who's uh who's on team smith
here
who's who's with you who's your team oh
me my mentor mom
pops your your mentor is
is your father is what you said or or
you have a different one other than your
pops
no so he's just my mentor just been with
me all my life taking me to camps and
things like that
what's his name vincent sanders okay
so what's your real yeah and he's been
taking you to camps and he
was he the one who who let uh nick saban
through her front door
did nick personally walk into your house
to recruit you
yes sir all right what was that day like
for you
um it was exciting just sitting down
talking to him
and just seeing what how he approached
things and his mindset of things so it
definitely opened my eyes
in some situations and it just made me
made my decision a whole lot easier how
has he affected your life
nick saban um he he affected it a lot
just with how he carried himself how he
approached things and just the mindset
of the business mindset that he has and
how everything his business with him
okay what's the most you've ever pissed
him off devonte
um i don't think i really did nothing
too
too too bad for real really i'll pro
i'll probably say um
something i did during the game or
something like that he probably
got mad they probably got him about well
it wasn't that too crazy look at you
because
i've asked everybody literally any
alabama player in the last several years
coming on this show
this question and each one of them has
had the exact moment where they knew
that they did something to have coach
volcanically erupt including two two had
one
two had one even so you haven't had one
of those moments where you go uh-oh
at all yeah yeah it was during during
the game
i mean it probably it's quite a time
quite a few times in the game
i did something wrong and you got on
what'd you do
did he come after you and after you
dropped that one against michigan state
that you referred to earlier did he say
something or no
no he ain't saying that then but i'll
probably say a miss block or something
like that he
he got on me about okay um so what's
going on with autotrader what are you
what are you doing on behalf of
autotrader
devonte uh auto trader is the go-to
resource when car shopping and with
everything going on
um with me being busy with training and
rehabbing
they just make me find in the car easier
and
that's probably gonna be my first big
purchase so partnering with them
uh makes it a whole lot stress less
stressful on me
and i'm excited okay what are you
looking at what are you checking out
what are you thinking about right now
uh probably a g wagon a g
wagon that's somebody who's thinking
about signing bonus right now
um how did you choose the jacket for the
heisman
i loved it i've i think i thought that
was
next level walk me through your jacket
choice
for the heisman well man my mentor we
always
um sit down and talk about like the suit
of the week and things like that so
when that time came we just came up with
something we um kind of visioned it and
it just kind of happened and that's what
we wanted to go with
it happens crimson velvet just happened
is what you're saying
that just happened yeah that's what you
want to call it
what was it is that not what that's what
i i thought to myself that's crimson
tide color
velvet to me no that's not what it was
what was what's the official what's the
official name for what you wore
heisman knife i want to say it was kind
of like a dark brown root bearish color
okay all right maybe i need to adjust my
television set
all right maybe that's maybe that's what
i got to do
i thought it was sharp it looked
phenomenal and i think you you're going
to be looking back on these photographs
going oh yes
that's what you're going to be saying
where is the heisman right now
where is the heisman it's um in
tuscaloosa
what do you mean what in your in your
apartment or is it in
no it's at the complex yeah yeah taking
care of it for me right now
okay so somebody's taking where where is
it right now
at the complex at the facility yeah
that's yours though isn't it
yeah i just kept it down to i found out
where i'm gonna be it
okay so i ain't gotta just be carrying
around about it so you just like say
coach you take care do you say is that
what you said coach you take care of
this or
or how did that happen yeah i say yeah
y'all can just hold it until i
figure out what i'm gonna do
[Laughter]
i look forward to chatting with you next
devonta
when uh when you're you know you're
going through everything
and just can i can i give you a couple
sense of advice
if you don't mind yes sir okay you're
going to hear a lot of crap you're going
to hear a lot of garbage about what you
can't do
or how tall you are and you're not tall
enough or you're not strong
enough and you're not built enough and
you don't weigh enough you're going to
hear a ton of that
don't listen to a single one of those
things and if you do somehow
some way draft have a draft night where
you last
longer on the board than you
[Music]
thought you should the team that gets
you is going to get somebody who makes a
tremendous amount of plays
and has a chip on his shoulder and you
just remember all the teams that passed
on you
and you just circle those dates on the
calendar and you just go bu
how does that sound yes sir okay
and uh and good luck to you i really
enjoyed watching you play this year
really was dynamite congratulations on
that and for your future
thank you you bet that's devante smith
right here on the rich eisen show